I named and here's my lovely girlfriend
as I don't know how many people suggest
that there's honestly but we're here to
play some Anisha we're alone in the
darkness but yeah we're gonna hey Josh
yeah go get out of here
ah ah doing that get out of here alright
someone says controlling the movement
and I'm the way get daddy baby here we
don't have the lantern right oh man
Oh what is this alright hold our yay how
y'all doing
I'll rake it alright he needs a bath all
right there was no less meaning hello
if you don't know how to continue
remember the to check paintings shelves
or note one key is hovering in the air
and another is in your sheets bed
Yoshi alright moving there you're not
really like ah okay so but didn't you
say something about Yoshi yeah I can
jump space no no I don't think anything
yeah yeah let's take a bath I don't go
in there
alright we'll take the pony we think I
should we name him her little lovey
No get out of here oh there's something
that we should go there Oh go faster me
lad Dan oh okay okay we're good welcome
Holly he's at noodle and ain't a sight
and I'm anti sight kin and your holy
neon noodle of course can you escape
from the long fight they already asked
my dad if I argue
I don't get it would hablar I don't get
it wait let me help us in would please
then let's go all right fine
Lindley right little Abby oh you get so
much pity no he's not dead all right I'm
not um you're doing and walking I can
take it from here and you slam stop
wasting your laughter Marcia I felt good
I feel really good
all right pony let's go hey where's the
key there give it to me all right
picking up the key to and your house we
need press tab if you know time it's all
right so far so good
almost nearly oh no car - race rain okay
hey what is this crowd control it's
right there under
I haven't got a present hi Morris I'd
never stop skimmable treshots [ __ ]
down fresh heads
take it maybe once on the hell is going
yeah I am tagging it the landing stop
wasting your life not just yet
get oh there's someone in here like you
it's creepy what are you doing don't get
so close all right we didn't figure out
how to progress in the second map so we
try to know their cousins already said
this one is called mine of Mateus how's
it going bros money here's my girlfriend
yeah they're back again let's just take
the key
let's take you know RL denotes this is
Stefano so we tried piggy but we
couldn't progress there was a bug so
let's go in here and you have to use the
key no oh okay let's go
Stefano we always say oh snap dr. Peggy
what are you doing at I just piggy doing
in Stefano's house same time but I want
pig it with me turn on the light thing
yeah yeah sup everyone lovely girlfriend
you have that beauty mmm
everyone having a good time tonight mmm
you know if you're interested maybe we
can have a little what nah done
oh you see she's into it she wants it
it's just you all right babe just you
and me then all right let's go before
you to start doing something all right
wait don't go down here for pinkie go
back a little bit it's a really cheap
job taking yeah with we try to taste it
fine this map was bug after a certain
point so we came up on this one as well
but we found another custom story and
this one we actually finished all right
how's the camera we're back with another
custom story is supposed to be something
really quick and do it Oh pity
that's quite a lady got their pity I'm
proud of ya can't even stand straight if
she doesn't know the control driveways
you're gonna hurt him girlfriend all
right now I'm spinning today what is he
doing to me why would you hurt me down
put me chair what a creep Pope ah he's
so out of there
he's so freakin out of there all right
put on the strap waiting on his king I
want lambs like this is awesome let's
loot knees I can't oh wait okay a
tinderbox anybody's like the most
pointless thing ever
yeah but you're a better player than me
what were you gonna say okay yeah all
right let's go here Joe please I talked
to the accountant Daksha okay there was
another door that I think no there
wasn't we have to find a key
maybe underneath yes yeah yeah yeah yeah
hold shift now can you hear I was
pressing shoot
really Jessie I love ya have it I think
you press too many buttons at once
that's right
I'm pressing [ __ ] I'm pretty sure on say
I just wanted you all right Wes Theresa
hello what are you ready to run this
time I'm K yeah you were really good you
know how to do it no we have to find ya
all right get down stupid books books
aren't good for anything
okay let's hide in the closet this time
all right go
okay yes yes I think we did it
Atlanta the ladder the ladder
do you know
I said he crazy all right
run run III that's okay hey it's oh yeah
sweet oh oh what the hell
ah I with you isn't it manager that two
of them don't trust anyone
oh you see that balance all right my
foot is nearly off I get out alive and I
never eat it I would what Oh food I read
okay my foot this nearly all right
let's go to the piano hey what oh why is
it coming noises if you
Oh behind us all right
go behind Athena gah gah okay relax on
the bottom line imagined I would okay we
need to jump up there nice jump well
done all right hope it's not like yeah
oh hey I was born one of these
okay stop why are they bouncing you're
not all affected
there's gotta be fish got bad
in your life don't know what Amar's come
why would they put a closet in the water
wow you're really bad opening me oh cool
oh yeah yeah low cry why I'm trying just
a plain old car by just a plain old
crossfire
yeah it ain't on Dropbox just plain
alcohol but just the plain old crony
okay let's you think you owe my dad all
right
oh I'm so strong you know this yeah
and
yeah hey Todd sirs
goddamn huge key have a you know I'm
kidding Todd said nothing
tom says all right I don't think I'll
say something
let's go here and you see you Chester
what is that that's a crowbar screaming
- lovely alright let's do one more Matt
oh he's so sexy sexy sexy he's so sexy
Geronimo ah ah
that hot how much did alive its emit
what hmm
I think you just have to go there hey
maybe you don't hurt me no ma that was a
really sure yeah but we only played once
I think you'll be enough
all right leave a comment in the black
and all that kind of stuff
she want to see us play more amnesia
together I'm sure a lot of people oh
this is lame it was more I don't know no
everyone loved yeah right I love her so
you would love her too
alright anyway
[Music]